Una forma de visualizar un conjunto es usando
un Diagrama de Venn, es decir, encerrar en un
círculo sus elementos constituyentes, mientras
que el conjunto universal se representa con una
línea cerrada exterior que casi siempre tiene
forma de rectángulo. Por ejemplo, aquí tenemos
el conjunto de las vocales a, e , i, o, u, y por
acá tenemos el conjunto con algunas consonantes,
digamos r, s, t. En este caso podemos decir que el
conjunto universal es el conjunto con las letras
que representamos en este diagrama: a, e, i, o, u,
r, s, t. Veamos otro ejemplo. Imagina que tenemos
este nuevo diagrama de Venn. ¿Puedes ver qué
elementos tienen el conjunto A, el conjunto B y
el conjunto universal? Pausa el video e inténtalo.
Muy bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Primero
observemos qué elementos están dentro del conjunto
A. Podemos ver que tiene el 1, el 8, el 3, el 5 y
también el 2, ya que, observa, está encerrado en
el conjunto A, es más, vamos a sombrear todo lo
que le pertenece al conjunto A. Ahora observemos
qué elementos tiene el conjunto B. Podemos ver que
el 10 está en el conjunto B, también el 4, el 6 y,
¡mira!, también el 2 está encerrado en el conjunto
B. Podemos sombrear de color azul todo lo que le
pertenece al conjunto B. Observa, entonces el 2 le
pertenece tanto al conjunto A como al conjunto
B. Bien, por último, pero no por eso menos
importante, pensemos en el conjunto universal
para este caso particular. Y puede ser que estés
tentado a decir: "¡Muy fácil!, sólo ponemos todos
los elementos del conjunto A y del conjunto B y
acabamos". Pero ten cuidado, eso no es del todo
cierto. Si ponemos los elementos del conjunto A,
tendremos el 1, el 8, el 3, el 5 y el 2; ahora,
si agregamos los elementos del conjunto B,
tendremos el 10, el 4, el 6 y también el 2. ¡Pero
ojo!, ya agregamos el 2 como parte del conjunto A,
no debemos cometer el error de escribirlo de
nuevo. Y ¿hemos acabado? No, nos hacen falta estos
dos elementos; no hay que olvidar poner todos los
elementos que estén en el diagrama de Venn, así
que escribamos 7 y 9 y ya está, podemos sombrear
de color blanco todo lo que le pertenece
al conjunto universal, es decir, todo. Veamos
otro ejemplo. Ahora trabajemos con el siguiente
diagrama de Venn. ¡Esto me recuerda a una pizza
hawaiana! ¿Puedes señalar los elementos del
conjunto A, y los elementos del conjunto B, y los
elementos del conjunto universal? Pausa el video e
inténtalo. Muy bien, trabajemos juntos. Empecemos
con el conjunto A. Si sombreamos el conjunto
A podemos ver que sólo tenemos un elemento: la
piña, así que el conjunto A es el conjunto cuyo
elemento es la piña. ¿Recuerdas cómo se llaman
los conjuntos con un solo elemento? ¡Claro,
unitarios! Así que podemos decir que el conjunto A
es un conjunto unitario, y podemos recordar que el
cardinal del conjunto unitario es 1. Bien, veamos
el conjunto B. Si sombreamos el conjunto B de
color azul, podemos ver que tiene como elementos
el jamón, el queso, la salsa de tomate, la masa y
también el conjunto A, es decir, la piña. En este
caso decimos que el conjunto A está contenido en
el conjunto B o que A es un subconjunto de B.
Y ¿cuál es el cardinal de B? Bien, si contamos
los elementos de B podemos ver que tiene 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, entonces su cardinal es 5. ¿Qué hay
del conjunto universal? Bueno, el conjunto
universal tiene los mismos elementos que B,
es decir: el jamón, el queso, la salsa de tomate,
la masa, la piña y, hay que agregar los elementos
que están fuera de B, es decir, el refresco y
el postre. ¿Cuál es su cardinal? Bueno, podemos
ver que tiene 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 elementos:
el cardinal de este conjunto universal es 7.
Aquí podemos observar algo importante: cualquier
conjunto, ya sea A o B, o el que sea en otro caso,
siempre será un subconjunto del conjunto
universal, ya que todos sus elementos están
siempre contenidos en el conjunto universal. Bien,
tengo una pregunta para ti: ¿cómo se representa el
conjunto vacío en un diagrama de Venn? Pausa el
video y piénsalo. Muy bien, trabajemos juntos.
Primero vamos a dibujar el conjunto universo, y
ahora ¿cómo dibujamos un conjunto vacío? Bueno,
el conjunto vacío es un conjunto que no tiene
elementos, entonces ¿qué te parece si dibujamos
un conjunto sin ningún elemento como este? Esta
es la forma de representar al conjunto vacío en
un diagrama de Venn. Y ahora, si pensamos en
las operaciones básicas de conjuntos, unión,
intersección y complemento, ¿cómo las podemos
aplicar al conjunto universal y al conjunto vacío?
Primero trabajemos con el conjunto universal. ¿Qué
obtendremos de la unión del conjunto universal con
cualquier otro conjunto? Bueno, la unión es el
conjunto que tiene todos los elementos de los
conjuntos que se unen, entonces la unión de un
conjunto con todos los elementos del universo te
da de resultado el conjunto universal, ¿cierto?
¿Qué obtendremos de la intersección del conjunto
universal con cualquier otro conjunto? La
intersección es el conjunto que contiene
los elementos repetidos de ambos conjuntos,
entonces ¿qué se repite entre el conjunto y
el conjunto universal? Bueno, pues sólo se repite
el otro conjunto completo, ¿cierto? Y ¿cuál será
el complemento del conjunto universal? Bueno,
recordemos que el complemento es el conjunto
de los elementos que le faltan para llegar a ser
el conjunto universal. ¿Qué le falta al conjunto
universal para ser el conjunto universal? Nada,
entonces la respuesta es el conjunto vacío. Ahora
trabajemos con el conjunto vacío. ¿Qué obtendremos
de la unión del conjunto vacío con cualquier
otro conjunto? Si unimos los elementos de un
conjunto con un conjunto que no tiene elementos,
entonces ¿qué obtendremos? Bueno, obtendremos
como resultado el conjunto A, ¿cierto? ¿Y qué
obtendremos de la intersección del conjunto vacío
con cualquier otro conjunto? La intersección es
el conjunto que contiene los elementos repetidos
de ambos conjuntos, pero ¿qué se repite entre el
conjunto y el conjunto vacío? Bueno, no se repite
nada, porque el conjunto vacío no tiene elementos,
entonces la respuesta es el conjunto vacío.
También podemos recordar que el conjunto vacío
es un subconjunto de todos los conjuntos, por
lo tanto, es la intersección. ¿Y cuál será el
complemento del conjunto vacío? Recordemos que el
complemento es el conjunto de los elementos que
faltan para llegar a ser el conjunto universal.
¿Qué le falta al conjunto vacío para ser el
conjunto universal? ¡Todo!, le faltan todos los
elementos que tengamos en el universo, entonces
la respuesta es el conjunto universal. Y eso es
todo por ahora. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.